hey guys this is andrew for trading
census.com i've been working as a
professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong and right now guys
i'm doing youtube videos
because i want to pass the knowledge as
i always say i want to show you the
different tools and techniques that i
use
that work for me and i know how to use
them so i want to show you guys all the
stuff
so if you want to know about how
actually to make money on the market
you guys are in the right place so today
i want to make
another update on gamestop because i
know that a lot of you guys
have interest in the stock so let's get
into it
[Music]
so guys uh the past few days i did some
analysis using idiot wave theory
i did the short term analysis and now
here i want to show you guys some levels
some targets that are that are actually
coming from
all the stuff i did before so here
for those who have watched my video on
the idiot wave
theory that i was applying here i was
seeing basically that had
one first move up here one two three
four
five so this will move up that then
corrected so it's from the really
beginning when we started at 2 we go to
480 we correct and
now we are going higher so let me get
rid of all this stuff
all right so this is more clear so we
have one two three four five that is
complete
abc we correct and now i am expecting
another one two three four five
and the question is where can we
go with this fifth wave so for now we
are only in the third wave so i think
the
the third wave is going to uh 480 to the
all-time high that we had here
then we're probably going to correct and
then i think we're going to
blow up this resistance with a very
strong move
and that we are going to uh go to 800
so i'm gonna show you guys why i think
this is what's gonna happen so first
idiot wave theory is telling me that
this is the most likely scenario
but i have other reasons and i'm gonna
give you targets so let's start with the
different reasons
so if you have a look at the short
interest so as usual guys i go on market
watch
so i think this data has been updated
now so i see 26 percent
uh but it's not you know it's not that
big but
what is interesting is look guys what
investors are doing
so this guy for example bill gross the
legendary billionaire investor and
co-founder of pacific investment
management blah blah blah
told bloomberg television that he made
about 10 million us dollar betting
against the stock
all right fair enough you want to bet
against the stock you want to get
destroyed
your choice but what is interesting here
is that he's selling coal options at 250
and 300 which he sees as the perfect
opportunity
so guys what does it mean it means that
the short interest that you're seeing
here
26 is actually only the real short
interest but you have some synthetic
short interest that is created by this
options all right
if you sell a call and you buy a put
you are actually short 100
of the notional so it's another way that
you can use to
short stocks and it's used by uh some
guys
like this rich investors so guys the
short interest is not that big but the
real short interest if you add the
synthetic uh
the synthetic short interest is probably
much higher
and another thing that is interesting is
that the strikes
he's selling are around 250 300.
let me show you guys again the chart so
if we go here at
480 he's gonna get destroyed
why because his gamma is going to
increase so the gamma is actually the
acceleration
you can say of the uh price action with
the spot
so basically the more the spot goes up
the more he is
short and the more the quicker he is
short actually
uh because his delta is actually um
increasing as well so whatever i don't
want to make it too technical i'm an
option trader you know so
but it's not the purpose of the video
here what is interesting for you guys to
remember is that you can have a gamma
squeeze so go check it out what it is i
can explain quickly but it's basically
this
increasing acceleration is this
acceleration of
uh the the position the short position
when
the spot goes higher and this is gonna
make that the short interest is
increasing on the upside
so if we come close to this levels
so first you're gonna have this gamma
squeeze and you're gonna have
some hedge funds that are short 25 is
not that low all right we went to 100
before but 25 is still substantial
and those guys they probably have stop
losses around 480.
so if we break 480 even if we get close
to this guys it's not gonna hold it's
gonna get
get destroyed and this is i think what
is playing out
so now i give you targets guys how do i
do
it's not easy to be honest here you
don't have any
uh past reactions so you can't find you
know some basic
uh resistance level like i did for 480
you know for it is obvious everybody
knows it's a resistance level
but here i'm going to use fib extensions
that work very well in this kind of
environment so you just measure that's
why iliot wave principle is very useful
to do prior to using fibs because you
need to know your waves
so here you know that the first wave is
starting here and going here
one two three four five
first wave you apply this to the bottom
of the second wave
second wave is the abc i have here
so it's like here guys and this is
telling me
that the most likely level it can be 500
all right if you have a one-to-one
relation
but guys if we go to 500 for the reasons
i just
explained you're gonna have the gamma
squeeze you're gonna have a short
squeeze you're gonna have the hedge
funds cutting the positions
so if we go to 500 we go got the next
one and the next one guys is 790
last time i said 780 let's call it 800
guys
we are going to 800 this is my view
and i just gave you the reasons so if
you guys enjoyed
this video please don't forget to click
the sub like and bell button so you're
going to be the first to know when i
upload anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys